je est un autre ça sonne bizarrement pas
vraiment français me direz vous vous
avez raison
les puristes appelle cela une aberration
syntaxique et pourtant cette affirmation
est celle d'un au grand poète arthur
rimbaud et donc ce que je vous propose
ce soir c'est d'aborder sous un angle
scientifique
cette affirmation d'ordre philosophique
pour le moins paradoxal je est un autre
jeu chacun d'entre vous que les jeux je
sais moi je sais chacun d'entre vous
mais êtes vous sûr de bien connaître
votre jeu est de savoir ce qui se cache
derrière ce jeu c'est pourquoi avant de
chercher qui est cet autre dont nous
parle le poète nous allons essayer d'en
savoir un peu plus sur qui est jeu pour
cela je vous invite à un voyage
exploratoire au coeur des deux univers
qui constitue le jeu à savoir d'un côté
la matière et de l'autre ceux qui
l'animent la vie et pour commencer
ces deux images
étrangement ressemblant dont ces soleil
entouré de planètes en gravitation dans
une ronde intemporel et pourtant vous
pouvez admirer d'un côté l'infiniment
grand
notre système solaire et de l'autre une
toute petite partie de moi toute petite
partie de vous une toute petite partie
de jeu l'infiniment petit un atome
mais cette similitude ne serait tel que
visuel est il possible que ces deux
infinis de fass cas est bien ce que nous
savons aujourd'hui de ces deux univers
et qui sont en fait gouverné par les
mêmes lois de la physique et de la
mécanique et que rien en dehors de leur
taille relatif de différencie vraiment
mais concentrons sur notre atom
ce que nous en connaissons et de fruits
du travail de nombreux scientifiques qui
grâce à leur exploration ont pu petit à
petit élaborer des modèles permettant
d'expliquer sa structure il a
certainement fallu une forme de génie un
certain 20 des nefs pour établir en 1869
le fameux tableau périodique des
éléments tableau qui encore aujourd'hui
considéré comme la clé de la
connaissance de la matière cette matière
qui nous constitue et nous entoure bien
que rudimentaire à l'époque de sa
publication
il est aujourd'hui sous sa forme la plus
aboutie l'organisation de ce tableau de
ce tableau est basé sur une idée simple
que l'atom est un système planétaire
avec en son centre un soleil le noyau et
tout autour répartis sur différentes
orbites tels des planètes satellite des
électrons ce tableau regroupe tous les
atomes susceptibles de composer toute
matière existantes les informations
qu'il contient permettent à tous
physicien hutu chimiste de comprendre la
nature et des propriétés de chacun
d'entre eux et de pouvoir prédire leur
possible des interactions maintenant que
nous savons que notre jeu est constitué
d'atomes essayons d'en savoir un peu
plus sur ce qu'il anime bien que mende
et lief nous est fourni une boîte à
outil qui nous permet de comprendre la
matière dans le monde et fait ceci ne
nous explique en rien sa spécificité et
en particulier ce qui en fait sa
singularité
notre monde n'est pas fait que de
matière il est aussi fait de vie mais
qu'est ce que la vie
en quoi un être vivant se différencie
d'un objet inanimé ou d'une machine
jusqu'à une époque récente on étudier
ces questions dans le cadre d'une
science appelé histoire naturelle
silence dans laquelle étaient inclus
pêle-mêle la géologie la chimie la
physique l'astronomie va
deux programmes d'enseignement mais
derrière cette question épistémologique
se retrouvent surtout une question
d'ordre philosophique et théologique
toujours en suspens d'où vient la vie et
comment la définir et bien aujourd'hui
encore les biologistes eux-mêmes et
beaucoup d'autres n'ont pas de réponse à
cette question
pendant longtemps on a cru que les
doigts de la chimie régissant vivant
était différente de celle de la matière
inanimée
mais depuis la synthèse de nombreux
composés organiques
il est clairement admis que ce sont les
mêmes lois de la chimie qui s'applique
de la même façon à toute la matière et
bien sûr la matière vivante
c'est ce qui a conduit à la naissance de
la biologie biologie qui vient de pions
en grec pour vie elodie pour sciences
donc sciences de la vie
ce néologisme est créé au début du
xixème siècle par la marque qui nous dit
et je le cite le nick evans objet d'une
science particulière qui n'est pas
encore fondé qui n'a pas ça qui n'a pas
encore de nom et à laquelle je voudrais
le nom de biologie la lumière de ces
informations relatifs à la matière est
aux vivants qui constitue le jeu nous
avons cherché sous le microscope du
biologiste que je suis si quelque chose
pour relier notre jeu et notre autre
pouvons nous les maîtres des hypothèses
permettant de faire un lien qui unirait
tout ce qui nous entoure
qu ils soient vivants où il anime est
certain mais illustres prédécesseurs ont
consacré leurs vies à observer la nature
avec la conviction que toute question
que nous nous posons la nature il ya
déjà trouvé réponse un des constats qui
ressort de ces observations et que bien
que différentes toutes les formes d'âge
y partage des caractères communs sous un
concept d'universalité et les trois
principaux caractère d'universalité du
vivant retenu aujourd'hui par la
communauté scientifique sont tout
d'abord le carbone
qui sert de squelettes de molécules
organiques puis l'adn qui sert de
support à l'information génétique et
enfin la cellule qui est défini comme
étant la plus petite unité vivante
sa taille est habituellement de l'ordre
de quelques microns mais le terme petit
n'est pas forcément approprié car la
plus grosse cellules existantes ont pesé
jusqu'à 2 kg c'est le jaune de l'oeuf
d'autruche et la plus longue qu'ils
aient l'axone du calamar géant peut
mesurer de près de 12 m cette conception
du vivant basait sur le carbone l'adn et
la cellule reste cependant débat du en
particulier pour ce qui concerne la
cellule car les virus sur considérait
comme vivant par certains alors qu'ils
ne sont pas faites cellule pour ma part
je considère cette notion d'universalité
comme trop restrictive et pas vraiment
universel et je crois comme certains que
la vie est d'abord énergie et qu'à ce
titre tout l'univers est vivant y
compris bien sûr la matière minérale
cela étant il n'en reste pas moins que
la vie sur terre sous sa forme
classiquement admise a pour origine une
seule et même forme de vie désigné sous
l'acronyme anglais de luca pour en
français dernier ancêtre commun
universel et qui seraient apparues sur
terre il ya au moins trois points 5
milliards d'années
mais comment expliquer cette diversité
dans les formes de vie qui s'y sont
développées depuis eh bien il semble
exister dans la vie une force primitive
intime et répressibles de l'exploration
exploration des possibles l'exploration
spatiale et temporelle exploration
consciente ou inconsciente
là il apparaît par ailleurs que la
notion de vie n'a de sens qu'à travers
la notion de durée et donc de survie
mais comment faire durer une forme
vivante par nature instable et donc snr
la première réponse à ce défi à fut pour
nos ancêtres lointains d'explorer les
possibilités de réplication du soin par
la fonction de reproduction
il apparaît qu'il y avait plusieurs
voies possibles pour y arriver mais que
quelle que soit la voie explorée un
passage obligé était dans un premier
temps la création d'un support de
stockage de toutes les informations qui
font la spécificité d'un individu une
sorte de disque dur ce qui a survécu de
ce support et qui a traversé les
millénaires c'est l'adn
il a fallu des siècles à la science
avant de découvrir en 1953 sur le modèle
de criques et watson cette structure
moléculaire vieille de plus de 3.5
milliards d'années à la fois si simple
dans sa composition
un sucre quatre acides aminés mais c'est
riche de possibilités grâce en
particulier à sa structure en forme de
double à nice en effet cette structure
en forme de double hélice peut être
dupliqué en une autre double hélice il
se forme ainsi de nouvelles molécules
d'adn n identique
là au départ il n'y en avait qu'une
seule assurant ainsi la conservation de
l'information au cours des cycles de
vies successives des cellules c'est ce
qui fait de l'adn ce support universel
de l'information du vivant capable de
transmettre sous une forme d'algorithmes
mathématiques l'intégralité de la
complexité d'un organisme vivant son
hérédité
pour vous donner une petite idée du
potentiel de cette structure
sachez que le génome humain est composé
d'environ trois milliards de paires de
bases distribué dans 46 chromosomes
ceci permet une capacité de stockage
atteignant les 455 millions de
téraoctets par gramme d'adr soit 455
milliards de milliards d'octets par g à
titre de comparaison sachez qu'il vous
faudrait environ 25 milliards 25
milliards le dvd double face
pour stocker l'information contenue dans
20 g d'adr et à côté de ça vous avez une
chance sur 116 millions gagner le gros
lot à l'euro millions vous devriez
essayer c'est vraiment trop facile mais
la vie pour notre ancêtre explorateurs
n'est pas si facile et après cette phase
de création du support c'est trop face à
la deuxième étape de cette conquête de
la survie comment transmettre son disque
dur
la première voie de reproduction que je
a inventé est une solution simple jeu se
coupe en deux après avoir dupliqué son
adn et donne ainsi naissance à de
nouveaux organismes parfaitement
identique au premier
de nouveaux jeux solution simple et
efficace appelé multiplication
végétative et qui concerne encore la
majorité des espèces vivantes mais qui
d'offres que très peu de possibilités
d'évolution car ne permet aucune
modification de l'information génétique
transmise sauf mutation c'est la forme
naturelle du clonage mais cette capacité
exploratoire a pris sa forme la plus
performante et la plus évoluée avec
l'apparition il y a environ un milliard
d'années de la reproduction sexuée ou de
son vrai nom procréation là où deux de
nos jeux se coupe en deux mais en deux
demi je en spermatozoïde et l'ovule puis
se rencontrent pour en créer un
troisième un nouveau jeu mais qui n'est
ni jeu un nul 2 2 le plus extraordinaire
le plus génial dans cette solution c'est
l'intégration dans un processus
biologique de reproduction d'une
composante mathématiques
le hasard et ceci sous la forme d'une
redistribution aléatoire des fragments
d'informations que sont les jeunes c'est
ce brassage génétique
cette redistribution aléatoire
systématique des cartes chaque nouvelle
génération qui fait de chaque nouvel
individu un être unique susceptible
offrir une nouvelle voie d'évolution
pour son espèce je pense qu'il nous
apparaît maintenant évident qu'il est
impossible de séparer de la matière et
le vivant mais que malgré tout ce que
nous en connaissons et tous les moyens
techniques dont nous disposons notre
univers reste encore une vaste et nîmes
temps sur sa nature en tant que matières
que sur les conditions qui ont vu naître
la vie il n'en reste pas moins que plus
de trois milliards d'années après son
apparition la vie sur terre n'a pu se
développer dans la complexité qu'on use
qu'on lui connaît aujourd'hui que grâce
à l'exploration
elle a en particulier donné à l'espèce
humaine des facultés uniques la pensée
et la faculté de se savoir exister cette
intelligence permet à l'homme de
comprendre en partie le commandent la
vie mais il lui reste la grande question
pourquoi cette vie d'où viennent ces
aspirations qui anime chacun d'entre
nous qui nous conduisent à faire ce que
nous faisons à être ce que nous sommes
et ce que nous allons devenir l'homme en
tant qu'espèce est-il une finalité pour
la vie quand on voit les multitude de
formes qu'elle a pu prendre depuis son
apparition
question intemporel et source de
polémique depuis que l'homme existe mais
darwin nous apporte un début de réponse
en nous éclairant sur notre place au
sein du vaste monde du vivant une espèce
parmi les milliards de formes de vie qui
nous entoure et oui nous sommes là tout
petit au milieu de ce triangle rose
celui qui représente l'ensemble du monde
animal nous sommes aujourd'hui sept
milliards d'humains mais un gramme de
seul peut contenir plus de 1 milliards
de bactéries appartenant à plus de dix
mille espèces différentes
notre enveloppe charnelle est constitué
d'environ cent mille milliards de
cellules humaines
mais nous hébergeons dans notre ventre
environ dix fois
plus de cellules bactériennes le
microbiote et oui 10 % seulement de ski
vite en nous et humain je ne serait-il
que 10 % de ce qu'il croit être
surprenant n'est-ce pas mais le plus
surprenant c'est qu'il est aujourd'hui
démontré que cette vie qui nous habitent
ces autres conditionne en grande partie
via l'intestin
baptisé récemment notre deuxième cerveau
le fonctionnement de notre cerveau
nos pensées nos désirs nos émotions
arthur vain mot nous l'a dit en
introduction
je est un autre mais pascal se
questionner dans son ouvrage est pensée
qu'est ce que le mois ses intuitions des
penseurs serait-elle prémonitoire eh
bien il me semble qu'à travers ces
découvertes récentes
la science nous permet aujourd'hui
d'aborder ces questions philosophiques
sous un jour nouveau et nous offre
quelques nouvelles réponses possibles
permettez moi pour conclure de me
soumettre deux d'entre elles
tout d'abord ce que nous pensons être
notre jeu ne serait-il pas en réalité
une communauté de jeu qui nous ferait
parfois pensé être un autre et enfin
l'homme dans ce vaste univers
ne serait-il qu'un support parmi
d'autres permettent encore d'autres
l'expression symbiotique de différentes
formes de vie
luttant pour un seul objectif un seul et
même autre avis merci